exactly we have a question yes I'll just
remind people we're in the cosmic
queries I'd like to think of it as star
talk after hours I know okay go on what
do you got all right this is from a dr.
K my daughter is planning to take me to
Iceland to see the aurora borealis for
my birthday which season is best to view
the Northern Lights which season is best
to view the Northern Lights there in
terms of peak activity whoo okay what
kind of doctor is dr. K dr. K doesn't
say but I'm just gonna guess he is a
gynecologist but it could also be a
doctor of bet it's really any
accomplishment at that scale for us so
those are the two possibilities okay and
then also is it better to go during a
full or dark moon in short is there a
scientific way to maximize our odds of
viewing and if so how could we do that
okay so it's getting deep in on it's not
yet when can I get go on a vacation it's
give me the toys and even physics
mention Icelandic ponies so yeah when's
the best time to view the aurora
borealis here first Iceland is pretty
far north yeah and the farther north you
go or equivalently the farther south you
go below the equator the closer you get
to the poles the longer is your Twilight
mm-hmm and the longer are the days and
the longer are the nights depending on
what season area you don't want to go to
Iceland in the summer where the Sun is
up for 18 hours a day and the rest of
the days you're living in Twilight
because you want it to be as dark as
possible to see the aurora the aurora
are not bright enough they're going on
all the time they're not bright enough
for you to see in broad daylight you
have to wait for the nighttime you don't
want to be there during a full moon the
full moon is the astronomers worst
nightmare because at night you go from
seeing 3,000 stars whereas a night where
there's no moon where it's a full moon
that drops to 300 so it's draw flight
polish actor if it's essentially light
pollution when you have a full moon so
you don't want to go in the summer so go
in the dead of winter you don't want to
go during full moons so look it up on
the tables find out when there's last
quarter to new moon back to first
quarter so you want to go basically at
the smallest liver and
smallest sliver or no moon and when
Iceland has the longest night winter
that would be the winter near of
eighteen hours of night it's the inverse
of what goes right right summer so it's
depressing but beautiful and so that so
the argument for when to go to Iceland
has nothing to do with the Sun it has to
do with maximizing the darkness of your
skies right so now you what you want to
do is wait for solar max all right every
11 years the Sun kicks in and becomes
more active there are more sunspots
there are more solar flares and more
solar storms and these things belch up
charged particles from this Sun surface
it scatters into the space of the solar
system it reaches Earth it sees our
magnetic field our magnetic field guides
these particles in towards the poles
they collide with our atmosphere render
our molecules the globe therein is the
aurora borealis and Aurora Australis
there are in the south so you want to
wait until the Sun is peaking then go in
the Icelandic winters without a moon and
you're good to go so this so what answer
is going around December January and the
other is every 11 years in December or
January say this person this is dr. gay
doesn't want to wait 11 years you're
saying go in the winter oh you you would
you would still see it it would still be
pretty it just wouldn't be the maxim
well it's best when you have good old
good good activity on the Sun yes but
otherwise I mean there's a whole you
know next year would you know when the
next time this right now we're
approaching solar maximum so meaning is
it Soviet peace next year next year
getting 2013 with the time it peaks in
2013 yes yes yes so that's a great
answer so now you just have to wait one
year okay that's a pretty reasonable
okay that's much better than the wait 11
years and hopefully you're not just
missed it man by the way the Sun is
always active and there's always the
solar and and so but you want you want
the the aurora to be kicking yeah yeah
oh yeah in 2012 it would be terrible to
see the 2013 no no it's it's a slow
ascent up to up to pee